ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Hey.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
My name is Artur
Oliveira, and I'm
very excited today
to host this talk
and to be able to introduce
Edan Lepucki to you.
Edan is the author
of "California."
It's her debut
novel, and she has
been billed as a brilliant
new novelist who just came out
with this book.
It takes place in California.
It's set in the near future.
And it's essentially the
story of a couple who's
trying to start a family in
this kind of dystopian future.
[APPLAUSE]
EDAN LEPUCKI: Thank you so much.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: So
Edan's going to start
with a quick, brief
reading from the book,
and then we're going
to do some Q&A. Thanks.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Thanks for coming, guys.
I, like any person, have
dreamed of coming to Google
to eat free lunch
for my whole life.
And I got to do it, and it
was really fun and delicious.
I suggest you try a sushi roll.
So as Arthur said, "California"
takes place in the future.
It's about a husband and
wife named Cal and Frida,
and when the book opens, they've
been living for a couple years
out in the woods by themselves.
And their nearest neighbors,
Sandy and Bo Miller,
have died under
mysterious circumstances
before the book begins.
In the first chapter, Frida
finds out that she's pregnant.
In the passage
I'm going to read,
she and Cal have recently had
an argument about whether or not
they should go find other people
beyond their small settlement,
because at this point, the
only people that they ever see
were the Millers, Bo and
Sandy and their two children,
but they're now dead.
And they see a man named August
who comes once a month to trade
goods, and he
basically tells them
that they shouldn't go
beyond where they live.
It's not safe.
But Frida thinks there's more
than August is telling them,
and she becomes
convinced that Cal
knows more than he's
telling her because he's
so concerned with staying put.
She basically feels like,
I'm going to have a baby,
we can't do this by ourselves.
We need to find out
who else is out there.
So in this section, Frida and
Cal have just had an argument.
August is the trader that
they see once a month.
He's on a horse-drawn buggy
with lots of goods to trade.
I think the only other piece
of information you need to know
is that Frida's brother Micah.
He was a suicide bomber in
LA and he blew himself up
at the Hollywood
and Highland Mall
in LA about five years
before the book starts,
and his name is Micah.
Has anyone ever been to the
Hollywood and Highland Mall
in LA?
Not a one.
This is the first
audience I've ever
had that no one has ever been
to the Hollywood and Highland
Mall.
It's a horrible mall and
you should never go there.
I mean, I consider myself
a connoisseur of malls.
It's really bad.
I'm so happy to be able to
warn you guys ahead of time.
I've saved your life.
So at this point,
this is in the morning
and Frida has left their house
to go do laundry at the creek
because at the end
of the world, you
don't have a washing machine.
So you have to do your
laundry at the creek.
"Frida pulled the
pants out of the bag
again and shook them
so they hung straight.
She walked over to
the big rock and lay
them flat across its surface.
It wasn't time to go yet.
She wasn't finished.
Cal wanted Frida to be pregnant,
and Frida wanted that too
if she was honest with herself.
It felt like a dare, the
biggest, most important risk
of all.
Micah might think so.
Before the group ruined him,
when his mind was still open,
fluorescent as
plankton, he might
have written her a letter that
said, 'Go ahead, believe in it.
Don't get all afraid on me.'
'I'm not afraid,' she said
aloud.
The way her voice sounded
in the morning air
made her turn around.
Was it some desire for a reply?
No one was there,
just the trees.
This didn't surprise
her, but she
did feel disappointed as
if she'd been stood up.
But by whom?
The creek rushed
along, oblivious,
and across the water,
the forest waited.
She and Sandy used
to go foraging there,
but they always stopped
before getting in too deep,
before the land became alien.
In a moment, she had the
mesh bag full of Cal's socks,
and she was crossing the creek.
The trees seemed to step aside
to let her into the darkness.
'After you,' they whispered.
She walked farther, in a
direction she'd never gone,
but there was a path
here slightly overgrown
and she saw the track
marks of August's carriage.
She knew he carried a scythe to
cut away brush as he traveled.
It was as if he had
cleared the way for her.
She draped a single sock
on the branch of a tree.
The fabric was gray and thin,
and it had once belonged to Bo.
Now it was a crumb that
would lead her back.
Hilda"-- that's her mother--
"Hilda and Dada and Micah would
be a fairy tale to her baby,
but for Frida, this world here,
the afterlife, was
the fairy tale.
If she wasn't
careful, Frida would
be eaten by a witch at
the end of her journey.
In a few moments,
August's tracks
led to a narrow trail, thick
redwoods on either side.
Frida paused, hands
clenching the bag of socks.
She sighed.
'I'm not afraid,' she said
again, as it to remind herself.
She placed a red sock on
a branch and kept walking.
Every few minutes or so,
she left a piece of clothing
for herself to find
on her way back,
and she would find her way back.
The longer she walked, the
more her chest tightened.
She'd felt like
this before, driving
lost in LA, her Navigator
and her Device dead.
She'd pass through a
rough neighborhood,
hoping to find something
familiar so she could breathe
again, blink again,
though by the end,
every neighborhood that
wasn't a Community was rough.
She was alert in
that same way now.
She had to pay attention, or
she might get turned around,
never find the
thread of the route.
The clothing
wouldn't be any help
if she headed in
the wrong direction.
She'd created a system.
Colored clothes meant turn
right, black and white ones
meant turn left, and
gray, head straight.
She kept her eyes on
landmarks-- the tiny stream,
the vines choking a thick
trunk, a lone crocus.
After she had walked
for about an hour,
she saw something
white up ahead.
She quickened her pace even
as she wanted to turn around.
It was a bathtub with
claw feet like a beast's.
The inside was
rusted out and filled
with brown rainwater, green
algae floating in its surface.
Something jagged
snagged Frida's throat
and she swallowed it down.
Here was evidence
of other people.
A person had
abandoned this here.
What was she doing?
She had to pee, and she only
had two pairs of socks left.
If Cal came to find her at
the creek, maybe to talk,
he would worry, and then
later, he'd be so angry.
She had to turn around before
she came upon other objects,
before someone stepped in
her path with a weapon.
But first, she
hiked up her dress
and squatted next to the tub.
She pulled down her
leggings and peed.
There was an atavistic
relief to this,
and her eyes watered
from the pleasure.
The end of the world couldn't
take this tiny joy away
from her.
She was a dog marking
her territory.
Frida was here.
As she stood, pulling
up her leggings,
her dress falling
back to her ankles,
a sound caught her attention,
something like a crunch,
like someone stepping
on fallen leaves.
She froze, that jagged thing
rising in her throat once more.
'Hello?' she whispered.
No answer.
Relax, she told herself.
It's nothing.
Couldn't be.
But still, she thought she
felt a presence not far
from where she stood.
Something, someone
was watching her,
its breath shaping the
molecules between them.
She was breathing
in that same air.
She stepped away
from the bathtub.
She would hurry back to the
creek and then return to Cal.
Nothing had happened.
She was safe.
From behind a tree,
another crunch.
The sound came from her
left and she turned.
A coyote.
It was standing
there watching her.
It didn't look like
the starving ones that
used to skulk around LA,
desperate for a cat to eat,
some garbage scraps.
This one was well fed, big,
with coarse, brownish gray fur
that looked prickly
to the touch.
If Frida didn't
know any better, she
might think she'd run into a
strange dog, tall and eerie
eyed.
It was so still.
A bird cawed above them.
Frida couldn't remember
what she was supposed
to do, yell at it to go away,
or step back quietly, or run
like mad.
This animal wasn't huge
but it could hurt her.
The coyote let out
a rasping sound,
its eyes arrowed into her,
and Frida noticed an animal
at its haunches, something dead
and small, a rabbit, maybe.
'I don't want it,'
Frida whispered.
She already had a
hand on her stomach.
Already, she needed to keep
her child away from this.
She could feel the fear growing
on her like a skin, a mold.
She could smell it.
The coyote pawed at
its meat, rasped again.
The dead thing had been
torn down the middle
and flattened like
roadkill, limp and bloodied.
The coyote turned back to
her and Frida read its body,
saw that it would pounce
if she didn't get away.
Above them, the bird
cawed once more.
Frida turned and ran.
On her way out of the
forest, away, away, away, she
grabbed every piece of clothing
she saw, held them in her arms
as if they could protect her.
'You look like a burglar,'
Cal said as she approached
the house with the wet bag
of laundry on her back.
'Help me with these,' she said.
She was still shaking.
'Sure thing.' Cal grabbed
the coiled rope hanging from
the side of the house, stretched
it to the tree across the yard,
and hooked it.
He kept looking back
at her as he did so
as if trying to figure out what
was different about her, as
if she'd just returned
in the beauty parlor.
'Are you all right,' he asked
when they were side by side
at the line.
'No.'
'Please don't tell me you're
still pissed at me.' Frida
shook her head.
'It's not that.
Just now, after I
finished the clothes,
I went into the forest.'
'You did what?'
'We need to find other people.
They're nearby.
I know it.' He didn't answer.
She squeezed his hand hard.
'Don't lie to me.'
'Why are you being so
careless,' he asked.
duplicitous?' He smirked.
'Good word.'
'I'm pregnant, Cal.'
'So now you're sure about that?'
'Would you rather I
be sick?' she asked.
She let go of his
hand and pulled
one of Sandy's old dresses
from the laundry bag.
It was wrinkled and cold.
He pulled it away from her.
'Let me,' he said.
'Just tell me what
you know,' she said.
Cal closed his eyes,
the dress in his hands.
She could tell by the
way his face scrunched up
that she almost had him, that
he'd do exactly what she asked.
He wanted to tell her.
He almost dropped the
dress but she grabbed it.
'I just washed
this,' she whispered.
"Please don't get it dirty.'
'I should have told you as
soon as Bo told me,' Cal said.
'What do you mean?' Frida
thought of the coyote
and the animal it had killed.
'Let's go inside,' Cal said, and
put a hand on her lower back."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: All right.
Thank you for that.
That was lovely.
You stopped just
before the good part,
right before the zombies attack.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Right.
The zombies just come
right around the corner.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: But
it's actually, I think,
when a lot of people
hear about this book,
the term "post-apocalyptic" is
usually used in the newspapers
and in reviews and
things like that.
And I think for us
nowadays, post-apocalyptic
is "The Walking Dead,"
it's "21 Days Later,"
it's things like that.
And hopefully this
isn't a spoiler,
but there's no
zombies in the book.
EDAN LEPUCKI:
There's no zombies.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: What
was your impetus
for the setting of the book?
How did you get there?
EDAN LEPUCKI: Well, to be fair,
when I thought of the book
actually as a book that
I would want to read,
not necessarily a book
that I would write,
I had thought of this phrase,
"post-apocalyptic domestic
drama."
So post-apocalyptic was always
in the equation of the project.
But I knew I didn't want to
write something really extreme,
one, because I didn't
really feel qualified
to write that kind of work.
The speculative fiction I read
is more on the Margaret Atwood
side of the spectrum
than something
more straightforward
science fiction.
So I felt like I couldn't
speculate into something
that was that different
from my current reality.
And I was really interested
in the domestic drama portion
of that phrase, and I thought
it would be really neat.
First of all, I was like,
I want to read this book.
I was not going to write it.
I was like, it would be so
neat to read a novel that's
about marriage but
have this other element
as this high stakes
backdrop, but really
focusing on this relationship.
And to be honest, people
ask me all the time,
so how did you decide to have
just a slow accrual of things
being bad versus one thing?
And I'm always like,
I just did that.
I didn't really think ahead of
why I was doing certain things.
There's no intention behind
anything in the book.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: But for
me, that was just so new,
and it was so different
from, I think,
most of the really popular
media that's out there.
And different in a
good way, I should say.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Well, I wanted
to make it feel realistic.
For me, I thought
the realism of it
would be what was
most scary about it,
because I think if
there's a singular event,
whether-- if it's
way in the future,
you think, well, anyone I know
will be just dead by then,
so I don't have to worry.
Or if it's a singular
event, there's
less agency in the creation
of that particular brand
of apocalypse.
Whereas this is only 40 years
in the future, maybe 45, 43
or something, so we
could all be alive
and our children will
be alive, and so I
think that's a lot scarier.
I'm hoping that readers feel
more complicit because what
Frida and Cal are going
through, a lot of it
is because of things
that we have to deal
or are refusing to deal
with in the present.
So there's been
climate change issues.
The very, very rich have
moved away from public space
and they just pay for
their own services
and they live in their own--
they're called communities
and it's impossible to get into.
There's a lot of those things
that we see in the present.
I basically took everything
that I felt really nervous about
and put it into the book.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: That makes
the story very relevant.
EDAN LEPUCKI: I hope.
That's my goal.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Absolutely.
So you mentioned the domestic
drama and you mentioned
their relationship,
and something
that stuck with me a lot
that Stephen Colbert said--
and we're going to get to him.
I know that this
book is inexplicably
connected to Colbert.
But when Colbert hosted
Hank Green, the author
of "Fault in Our Stars."
EDAN LEPUCKI: John Green.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: John Green.
EDAN LEPUCKI: I was
like, who's Hank Green?
That's an unknown author.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: He
said that a young adult
novel is a novel that
people actually read.
But I have to say that's not
how I felt about "California."
I didn't feel like
it was something
that you would use the term
young adult for because Cal
and Frida's relationship
was so real.
Their marriage was
so real, and it
was at a level that's a
lot more mature than what
would be in a quote,
unquote, "young adult novel."
So my question for
you is, how were you
able to create that
relationship in the book,
and how were you able to
make it realistic and mature?
EDAN LEPUCKI: Well,
first I have to say,
young adult-- I've got
to talk about that first.
Actually, a young adult
author, Cecil Castellucci,
she's my friend, and she says
that a young adult novel is
a novel that's
about young people
without the retrospective gaze.
So they're not far enough
away from their teenage years
to process it as an
adult, and they're
sort of living through it.
I kind of like that definition
because it doesn't catalog
the book based on
who's reading it.
It's based on subject.
I don't tend to read a lot
of young adult fiction,
but I know a lot of people who
do, adults and young adults.
I do hope that my book
has a level of readability
that it has in common with
some of the young adult novels.
And I think one of the reasons
why people are gravitating
towards those books is that they
do have a strong sense of story
and narrative propulsion
that I think is pleasurable
and people are returning to
that idea of storytelling
can be a pleasant experience.
I read adult fiction.
That's mostly what
I'm interested in.
I was just joking with
my same friend, Cecil,
about how I had just recently
read "The Love Affairs
of Nathaniel P.," which is about
this single guy in Brooklyn,
and I was joking with her
that one of my favorite parts
was the descriptions of
him cleaning his apartment.
And I was like, I really love
fiction where nothing happens.
I don't know why,
but if it's really
invested in the characters,
then I can go with it.
It's also better than actually
cleaning my own apartment,
probably.
I don't know where
that came from,
but it made me think about how
I can read about someone dusting
their mantel-- that
sounds like I'm
talking about something else.
That sounds like a euphemism.
I can read about someone
mopping their floors
if it's written about
from a strong perspective
of that person living.
So if we can get a real
understanding of what
it feels like to be
them in that moment,
you can get me interested
in basically anything.
Anything can happen,
plot-wise, if I'm
interested in the characters
and their consciousness
and their perspective.
So that's kind of where
I come from as a reader,
and also kind of how
I came to this book.
So I had this post-apocalyptic,
mid-apocalyptic landscape,
I guess, but that
was new for me.
And so what I was
really focusing on
were this married couple, Frida
and Cal, and just thinking
about who they were, and
where they came from,
and what made them
do what they did.
And really, I was just
moving with intuition.
I didn't really know where
the story was going to go.
I had this character in
the very first scene.
She didn't have a name yet.
She had a turkey baster
which nobody knew about.
And I just started
thinking, what
would have had to
happen to you in order
for you to take a turkey
baster from your hometown
and like hoard it in the
forest and not tell anyone,
including your
husband, that you owned
it and it was very
special and it
was a powerful object to you?
That was a really useful entry
into Frida and her humanity.
And similarly with
Cal, I had him
longing for memories
of college and thinking
about his single
mom who had died
in a snowstorm in
Cleveland, and using
that to push him to
think about who he was.
Because I didn't have an outline
of where I was going to go,
I would just put the
characters in a scene.
The novel switches
perspectives between them.
And so if I was
in a Cal chapter,
I would just really
think about, what
does the room look like to Cal,
based on the fact that this
happened to his mother, and
he went to college here,
and his best friend
was a suicide bomber,
and he's madly in love with
his wife who's kind of bratty
but he loves her anyway, all
of those things informing
every single choice,
sentence to sentence.
And just being with
them and treating them
like real people that existed
before the book starts and will
continue to exist
after the book ends.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: You mentioned
that the book changes
perspective from
chapter to chapter,
so one of the questions I
had when I was reading it
is, who is the main
character to you?
EDAN LEPUCKI: This
is really interesting
because people will be
like, obviously, Frida
is the main character, or
somebody else will be like,
Cal's the main
character of the book,
and to me, they share the story.
In some ways, I
think sometimes it's
Frida's story because
it starts with her
and she gets one more
chapter than he does.
So maybe she gets a
little bit more page time,
but it really is
their-- it's the story
of their relationship.
It's the story of where they are
at the beginning of the novel
and where they end up, sort of
the arc of their relationship.
They're together at
the end of the book,
but they're different.
And I'm interested in
what has happened to them
and how they have been
changed by the six weeks
that the book covers.
Do you think one of them
is more than the other?
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: No, I
didn't, which I only
realized about halfway
through the book.
Because you start
with Frida, I thought
well, she's the main character,
and then at some point in time,
something just clicked with me.
And maybe it speaks
to the marriage,
that it is a lot of give and
take between the two of them.
Even you as a reader
reading it, you can kind of
see that going back and forth.
EDAN LEPUCKI:
Also, it was really
fun to write a book where I
got one person's perspective
and they knew information that
the other one didn't and they
had two different
interpretations
of particular moments.
That was really fun
as a writer to do.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA:
They're never quite
sure what the other
one knows and what
they're not telling them.
EDAN LEPUCKI: It's so funny.
I am the worst secret keeper.
I just cannot keep secrets.
And this book, it's all secrets.
Just one secret
feeds off the other,
and I get asked
about it quite a bit.
What's up with the secrets?
But I've been thinking,
when you have a secret,
it's your own
private possession.
It's your own territory.
And this is a world where,
at the beginning at least,
it's just them two.
It's like the Frida and
Cal show all the time.
They really have
no private space,
except everything about their
lives is intensely isolating.
So I've thought about
the way that secrets, it
provides a space between them
in a hyper intimate environment.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: It
is a work of fiction,
so I don't want to
go into any spoilers.
If any of you have
read the book and you
would like to ask Edan
some questions afterwards,
you can certainly do that.
EDAN LEPUCKI: There's
some plot twists.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: A couple.
What I mentioned earlier, too,
is in addition to the book,
and in addition to
what I really believe
is a very unique
and very different
story with a unique
setting, the way
that the book burst onto
the scene was also pretty--
EDAN LEPUCKI: Crazy.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Pretty
creative and pretty crazy.
So do you want to
tell the story,
just because I'd love to
hear how you would tell it.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Sure.
I mean, I feel like
you all could just
go home and Google it.
I just wanted to use
"Google" in a sentence.
So my book is published
by Little Brown, which
is an imprint of Hachette,
and Hachette is still
in disputes with Amazon,
which is an online retailer,
if you're not aware of them.
I really want to
meet someone who
doesn't know what Amazon is.
I'm just waiting
for someone to be
like-- I mean, I have had
people at readings be like,
oh, I didn't know about Colbert,
and I love that part when
that happens, but anyway.
Has anyone not heard of Amazon?
Show of hands.
So Amazon and Hachette are
in this dispute over contract
negotiations, and
as part of-- I don't
want to use the word
"retaliation" because it sounds
a little bit overboard,
but Amazon removed
the Pre-order buttons from
any books being published
by Hachette that
weren't out yet.
And I didn't really know
this, but pre-orders
are a pretty big part
of a book's life.
You can kind of get a sense
of how well a book will
do by how high the pre-orders
are beforehand and that kind
of stuff.
So Colbert, he has a show called
"The Colbert Report" on Comedy
Central, and he's a
Hachette author as well.
He has books published
with Grand Central,
so he wanted to talk
about-- and also, even books
that weren't on
pre-order, Amazon
was delaying shipment for them.
So it would say, it will be
available in three weeks, which
is so different from
most things on Amazon,
which we can get in
like two seconds.
So he wanted to talk about
the dispute on his show, which
I was really thankful for
because I felt like it was
a book industry topic forever
that nobody outside the book
industry talked about.
And so I was glad that he wanted
to just bring the conversation
to the general public, because
I had friends who were asking me
about, how come I can't
pre-order your book,
and they had no idea that this
whole dispute was happening.
The book industry was in
a whole tizzy about it
and it didn't like
anybody else cared.
So Colbert was going
to talk about it,
and he brought in
Sherman Alexie,
who is really well known.
He's a Native American author.
He wrote "Absolutely True
Story of a Part-Time Indian."
That's one of his most
recent popular novels,
but he's a lovely guy.
I didn't know him beforehand.
He's very telegenic.
I think that's one
reason why he keeps--
he's really funny
and on the fly.
So he went on
Colbert to sort of be
the-- they could converse
about the dispute.
And Alexie decided he wanted
to talk about a debut novelist
because he felt like
it's really hard to be
a debut novelist in this world.
They sent him a bunch of
books and he picked mine.
I don't know.
I was not involved.
And then Alexie went on
and talked about my book.
I knew the day before
that it might happen.
I knew day of that
was going to happen.
But even after it
happened, I didn't
realize that it was going
to be this big thing.
Because once my
book was announced,
then Colbert had
everyone who was
going to show it
to Amazon order it
from Powell's, the independent
bookstore in Portland,
and he made it
like this campaign.
He started tweeting
about it all the time,
and then he mentioned
it a second time,
and then pre-orders were
just going up and up.
Then we were up to
9,500 or something,
and I went to Powell's.
I signed all of them.
And then my book
debuted at number three
on the "New York
Times" bestseller
list, which is
impossible to happen.
It never happens to
a first-time novelist
or any kind of novelist.
I don't expect this to ever
happen to me ever again.
And then I went on
Colbert to say hurrah
because it was really
was kind of miraculous
to have a literary novel,
post-apocalyptic but still
literary, from someone with a
totally weird name that nobody
had ever heard of.
I feel very grateful,
obviously, but also pleased as
punch that I am part of
this strange footnote
in literary history.
I think Amazon is obviously part
of a larger, long conversation
about publishing
and how books work
and all that kind of stuff,
and that when somebody writes
a history, there
will be a paragraph--
maybe I'll get a sentence--
about this thing that happened.
And I hope down below,
after "ibid, ibid, ibid,"
there'll be a little
line about me.
I feel like that's pretty cool.
So that's what happened.
It just has a crazy story.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: You can just
add that yourself on Wikipedia.
Just write yourself into the--
EDAN LEPUCKI:
Actually, Wikipedia
says that I was
born in Poland based
on a joke I made on something.
If anyone here knows
how to fix Wikipedia--
I know you have to join.
I know people can do it.
I know anyone can
do it, but then you
have to sign on and join.
It's like in "The Office"
where Steve Carell
is like, we can bring
YouTube down to film it.
That's sort of where I'm at.
But they think I'm from Poland.
I'm from LA.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: So you got
the Colbert bump, right?
EDAN LEPUCKI: I got the
Colbert mountain, basically.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Signed
10,000 books in two days?
EDAN LEPUCKI: Yeah.
I'm really good
at signing books.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: We've
got another couple
thousand here for you to sign.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Maybe
6,000, I think.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: So the dispute
between Amazon and Halette,
it's over actual
printed books mainly.
It's probably ebooks too, right?
EDAN LEPUCKI: Amazon is
famous for its secrecy levels,
really crazy levels of secrecy.
So there's not much
about the dispute that's
been known to the
public, but there's
one part that we do know that
is about the price of ebooks.
Amazon wants ebooks to be lower
because the pie of profits,
Hachette is making more
than Amazon would like.
I don't think
Hachette is totally
blameless in the situation.
I think if royalty
prices for ebooks
had been higher all
along for authors,
probably this wouldn't
have happened,
but when ebooks came
into the scene, somehow
the royalty share
for authors is lower
for ebooks than print books.
I know.
And I was like, I'm so
happy to have a book.
and I'll sign wherever.
Whatever you want,
I'll just do it.
But that's common practice is to
have lower royalties for that.
Amazon's argument is that
if an ebook is cheaper--
their argument is a little
bit questionable to me.
They're like, if
a consumer has $20
and if they buy an
ebook for $5, then
they'll spend their second
$5 on another ebook.
And I'm kind of like,
after you buy your ebook,
then you're going to
go buy your latte.
You're not necessarily
going to buy a book.
And I do also feel
like a book is not
just the actual physical
thing that you buy.
So when you buy a
hardcover, obviously, it
costs more because you're
paying for the hard cover,
but you're also paying
for me to write the book.
It took four years for
me to write the book.
You're paying my editor,
who did edits for a year.
You're paying the cover
designer and my publicist.
So many people go
into making a book,
so I think sometimes the
argument that an ebook should
be cheaper because it's
electronic is not always true.
I'm not saying that it
shouldn't necessarily be cheaper
in some cases, but
of course, I can
see Hachette's side
of the situation.
I also worked in
bookstores for a long time.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: And what do
you see as your perspective,
then, especially
with the ebooks?
Because Google has
the Google Play Store.
You can buy ebooks through
So what do you see
your perspective?
What should be the role of
technology companies like Apple
and Google and Amazon and
Microsoft in this space?
Because they do
provide a great value
to consumers and to authors,
but at the same time,
it's also a whole other layer.
EDAN LEPUCKI: I think it's
a really difficult question
because I recognize--
I personally, I
have read on my iPad, but I
don't prefer to read that way.
I like to read in the bath.
I like to eat and just get
grease all over whatever
I'm reading.
But I'm a minority book buyer.
I buy from an independent
bookstore at full price
and I don't care.
It doesn't bother me.
And I never really
shopped at Amazon,
but I recognize that I'm
different from another kind
of book buyer.
And I don't really
care how people read.
It's not like I'm like, oh,
I love the smell of books.
I don't like that.
If you want to read on
your Kindle, that's fine.
And I do think that these
companies are offering
great services to
readers, and I think
there's some things happening
in technology that are changing
how we consume media in
really interesting ways.
Everyone's always
years ahead of me.
I'm like, oh my god, and people
have been doing it for years.
But I do have a question
about, at what point
do we say that the cost of
content has gotten too low?
I feel bad for anyone who's
trying to make music nowadays.
I have a friend who's in a
band and she doesn't really
make any money at it.
She can tour, but her whole
band will make $600 for that one
evening, and there's
eight of them,
and then the DJ will come in
and he gets $3,000 for the night
and he's one guy.
I hear that kind of story from
a lot of different people.
And thinking about it from
a perspective of an artist,
if I'm going to spend
years and years on a book,
obviously I shouldn't get paid
for something that doesn't sell
or people don't
necessarily want to read.
But if people are paying
only $0.99 for it,
it just doesn't seem
like a tenable model.
So I don't know what the
answer is, but it is definitely
something that I feel
is troubling to me
and I don't know how to fix it.
I don't know.
Just blabbing now.
I'm sure everyone
here in the audience
has better ideas than I.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA:
But it's certainly
an interesting question
because it's not just books.
Like you said, it's music, it's
movies, it's apps, it's games.
It's everything
that's happening, too.
But also with that
digital space,
there's also a whole
other side of it,
which I haven't
heard talked about
too much in the
context of your book,
but there's also piracy, right?
You as an author, is that
something you worry about?
Is that something you think of?
Do you have a perspective on it?
EDAN LEPUCKI: I don't.
I haven't personally-- maybe I'm
good enough to be pirated now,
but before that, I wasn't.
I'm friends with Emily
Gould who does Emily Books,
and she's in subscription-based
book business.
You pay a certain amount a
month and you get a free ebook,
and it's non-DRM technology.
And she's tried to get deals
with publishing houses,
and I might be getting
this story wrong.
This is how I understand it.
But trying to get
publishers, let's
make "California" our next
Emily-- this hasn't happened,
but let's make this Emily
Books the next pick.
The publisher will say, no,
because of the DRM technology
of being able to pass the
book onto next people.
I tend to know quite
a few people who
work in the creative arts who
are against technology which
limits it to a single device.
Now I feel like I'm so
stupid because-- I'm
like a cave woman coming
into this shiny spaceship.
Because they feel like it's
actually more limiting than it
is protecting the artist.
So I feel like I know
enough people who
are in support of the freedom of
spreading technology in the way
that you would spread a mix
tape or something that I don't
really know where I
fall on the continuum.
Although I will say that it does
feel like everyone just wants
everything super
cheap or just free,
like I got my wedding
dress for $0.10.
I got these shoes for $1.
And you're like, do you know
the effects on the environment
that happened to make
you wear those shoes,
or what small child
had to make those?
I just feel like the
desire for things
to be cheaper and cheaper
makes me really uncomfortable.
But at the same time, is
it an inexorable movement
towards that?
I don't know.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: It's certainly
a difficult question.
EDAN LEPUCKI: I can't
believe this video is
going to be on the
internet forever.
[LAUGHTER]
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: I'll ask
you one last question.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Can
you ask me something
about, like, point
of view or something?
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: So wrapping
up with my questions,
because I would love to get some
questions from the audience,
too, if we can go
back to the book,
then, for one last question.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Stay in
your box, little girl.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: I kind of
asked you this before the talk,
but how much of
yourself is in Frida
and Cal and their relationship,
because-- correct me
if I'm wrong, but I hope I'm
not wrong-- I got the impression
that the characters
and their relationship
were just so real that it had
to come from somebody who kind
of knew what they
were talking about.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Well, in a
sense, every character is me
because they all
sprung from my mind,
but it's not me and my husband.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: That's
not what I was getting at.
EDAN LEPUCKI: No, I know.
People have asked me that.
I've gone camping
twice in my life,
and not since the early
'90s, and I'll never go back.
In this book, they live
out in the wilderness,
so I had to actually use
the powers of pretend quite
strongly and do a
little bit of research
to get them to live
out in the sticks.
I wanted to write a book about
marriage because I'm married
and I felt like a
lot of the books
I read about marriage are about
the dissolution of a marriage
through adultery, not that
that's not interesting to read,
but I'm kind of sick of that.
And I found Coach
and Tammy Taylor
from "Friday Night Lights," they
have a marriage on that TV show
that's really a very strong
and loving and dynamic and
believable marriage.
So that was another inspiration.
And I am happily
married, and I wanted
to write a book about two
people who actually were really
in love and connected.
The actual couple in
the book, I actually
don't know if they
are happily married.
By the time I got
to the end, I'm not
so sure about their
connection or what they had,
but that was kind of an
interesting process for me
to go through.
I mean, sure, there's
stuff from me in the book
and from people I
know, but they're not
based one to one in reality.
I just make up people.
You might see yourself
in my fiction someday.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Oh, wow.
EDAN LEPUCKI: If
you're not careful.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: A villain
in a book, perhaps?
EDAN LEPUCKI: Yeah.
I could do that for you.
Yeah, sure.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Cool.
Well, great.
So thank you so much.
Now I would love to
hear from you guys.
If you could please
speak into the microphone
so the folks on the live
stream and on the recording
can hear you.
AUDIENCE: You said the book
took you four years to write.
So how much of that
was first draft
versus revisions
and stuff like that?
I like to write.
I'm curious about every
author's full story
because it's just
interesting to me.
I just wanted to know more
about that process for you.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Well, let's see.
I started it in
September of 2009
and I sold it in
September of 2012.
So when I say four
years, I'm counting
the one year of the revisions.
The first year that
I was writing it,
though, I also stopped to revise
another book that never sold
and I wrote a novella, which
was more like a long story.
So there were couple month spans
that I would take time off.
It probably took me the
majority of the time
to finish the first
draft because I'm
a pretty careful writer in
that my first drafts aren't
these mad, messy spiels.
I write a chapter.
I look at it.
I figure out what
I want to do next,
then I write the next chapter.
I'll often go back
and rewrite as I go.
So I think probably
two and a half years
to write the first draft and
then another half of the year
doing revisions.
The book as it was
sold was probably
the third or the fourth
draft, and then I
did two more drafts
with the editor.
AUDIENCE: How much did it
change from start to end?
EDAN LEPUCKI: It's funny.
The version that is
published feels to me
like the version
it was fated to be.
And in some ways, it's very
different from the version
that I sold, and in some ways,
it's not different at all.
Actually, my brother
read the draft right
before it sold to help me
with botany information
because he's sort of
an amateur botanist,
and then he read the
book after it came out.
And he said to me, it
actually feels the same
except for things felt
different and I wasn't sure how.
And he said the ending
felt a lot different.
I probably cut 70
pages of flashbacks
from the first part,
which at first I was like,
I can't cut these, and
then as soon as I started,
it felt so liberating
to just cut the fat.
And then the last
100 pages, it always
ended up where it ended up.
It was almost like
Tetris, where there
would be some scenes
removed or different
things would happen in
a particular scene which
would affect the next scene.
But because the
characters were the same,
it actually didn't
feel like huge changes.
I don't know how
else to describe it.
Because Cal and
Frida and the people
surrounding them were
the same, so the plot
was almost superfluous
in some strange way.
AUDIENCE: I haven't
read the book yet
so I don't know all of the
apocalypses that are in here,
but you mentioned that they're
based on your anxieties,
and I'm just curious.
I probably have some
of the same anxieties,
so after writing
this book, how has
that changed your appraisal
of our current world
and its prospects?
EDAN LEPUCKI: You know,
it was in some ways
cathartic to write it.
Some readers have told me
it's a really scary book,
but when I was writing
it I didn't feel scared.
I almost felt
thrilled and powerful.
I always joke, I ruin
IKEA in half a sentence.
I'm like, see you later, IKEA,
and it feels really good.
But I'm still nervous
about a lot of the things.
And actually, sometimes I listen
to the news and I'm just like,
my book is like
unicorns and rainbows
compared to what's
happening at present.
I remember I was
listening to something
about-- there were
two occasions.
One time, I was listening
about the kids who
are coming from Honduras
across the border,
and some of the things
that their parents do
for them, like putting IUDs
in very, very young girls
before they send them
off to cross to get away
from horrible, horrible,
unspeakable acts of violence,
and thinking about how that
was so much harsher than any
of the things that
I'd put in my book.
And then I was listening
to something about Syria,
and I was just like, Jesus,
these things happen now
across the world, and
my book isn't really
that scary at all compared to
what's presently occurring.
I'd heard after
the climate summit
some of the decisions
that they had made,
it gave me a little bit more
hope than I had had previously.
I don't know if that
was just me being
a Pollyanna in the
moment, but I felt like,
OK, maybe we can get
things together, maybe.
But I'm still pretty nervous.
I think everybody probably
swings wildly between,
humankind is totally screwed
and we make all these choices
and we're just raping the earth
until there's nothing left.
And then you swing to the
other side and you're like,
as a species, we're
so innovative,
and we're so kind on
an interpersonal level.
I come into contact with
people who are really generous
every day, so how could
that exist along with that?
So I think we all go between
those two-- I mean, somewhere
in the middle, of
course, as well.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: As someone
interested in an MFA program,
I was interested
about your experience
at the University
of Iowa, and what
were your major takeaways
from your time there?
EDAN LEPUCKI: I went to
Iowa in 2004 to 2006.
I had a great time.
Iowa is a really
big program, so I
feel like I had a different
experience than other MFA
graduates.
Iowa has about 50 students
total, 25 fiction, 25 poetry,
and other programs
have six total,
so it's a very
different environment.
I will say that I'm
not a person who
thinks you have to get an
MFA or that MFAs are stupid.
It seems like there's
only two options now.
I kind of think an MFA can
work for a lot of writers.
It worked for me in terms of it
was a good time for me to go.
I was working full
time at a bookstore.
I was writing when I could,
but I couldn't really
carve out the space.
And then I was given two years
to read and write and meet
other writers, which is just
a really wonderful gift.
I run a private
writing school in LA,
and so a lot of the
students either have MFAs
or are applying to MFAs
or they're not getting in.
They run the gamut in terms
of MFA desire or experience.
And a lot of them end up writing
books and publishing books
without MFAs, and
so I don't think
that's a requirement to
leading the life of a writer.
I don't think anyone should
go unless they get aid.
It's not a lucrative
field, or isn't necessarily
a lucrative field, and
it seems like a bad idea
to go into debt to do it.
So if you go and you
end up hating it,
if you didn't pay for
it, then that's OK.
And I feel like if you know
you're spending $30,000 a year,
will that infect
your writing process
or make you feel like
you have to write
a certain kind of thing?
It just seems like it
puts a lot of pressure
on your short stories
that there should not be.
But I've met a lot of
great readers there.
That's probably the best
thing that I got from it
is getting lifelong
readers that I still
exchange work with and talk
about writing with and call
crying, that kind of stuff.
AUDIENCE: So when you talk about
the number of drafts you did,
when you say a draft, are you
putting it aside and starting
from beginning again, or are
you rewriting specific sections?
EDAN LEPUCKI: Well, it's funny.
"Draft" is such a loose term,
I feel like, because it can
refer to different-- actually,
Lauren Groff, the writer,
she's a wonderful writer.
She writes by hand, and
then she takes everything
she's handwritten and throws it
away, and then she starts over.
She's like, if it's
good, I'll remember it,
which is so horrifying to
me but completely admirable.
So I write everything
right onto the computer.
I usually have a
notebook with me
where I write, OK, what
did I do in this passage?
What do I want to do next?
I have a lot of notes.
But because I revise as I go,
then what draft number I'm at
is unclear.
Right now, I have a book.
I have 170 pages of it.
There are some sections that
I've written many times over
and other ones that
are just totally raw.
It might end up that some
of the totally raw stuff
will end up in a
published book someday.
I don't know.
Usually what happens is,
if I can remember clearly,
when I got to the end
of the first draft,
I wrote, "the end."
Then I'll print it
out, read through it,
make changes based on what
I think the book needs.
Usually, what I'll do is I'll
do like a pass that's just
for prose, and then I'll
do a pass that's like,
OK, I'm going to focus
on the flashbacks,
figuring out which ones do I
need, which ones don't I need.
Or I'm going to focus
only on the last 50 pages
because I feel like the conflict
resolution is really not
working here, or I'm
going to work on pacing.
I'll have an intention
for every single draft,
but all of those intentions
will encompass a single draft.
It will be part A of the
draft, part B of the draft.
And then when I
was with my editor,
for instance, the
first draft was all
about cutting the flashbacks
and adding world building,
and then the second
draft was all
about working on the plot
in the last 100 pages,
so they were focused per draft.
But they start to sort of blur
together of what draft is what.
I have a feeling
that in my future,
I will have some kind of project
where I'll write a whole draft
and then have to totally
dispose of it and start over,
but I haven't had
that experience yet.
AUDIENCE: What is that
decision making process for you
of switching to another book?
When do you give
up on a project?
EDAN LEPUCKI: That
other book, I have
a soft spot in my
heart for this book.
People ask me now, am
I going to publish it?
I'm like, no.
That book belongs in the drawer.
That book, I finished it.
My agent sent it out for almost
a year to different editors,
and there were too close
calls that were actually
very heartbreaking, where it was
like, they're going to say yes,
and then they couldn't
get the final approval.
But while it was
out on submission,
it was a whole year.
I started "California."
After it had been
rejected so many times,
and it got to the point my agent
would send it to 12 publishers
and we'd get back three nos, and
the other nine just didn't ever
read it.
It felt like a manuscript
that had no heat,
that nobody wanted to look at.
And so I gave her the first
100 pages of "California,"
and she was like,
this book is better,
and it's a little
bit more commercial,
which is sort of a gross word.
I don't think she was
being mercenary about it,
but she was like, you're writing
a book that you naturally
want to write, and I feel
like I will definitely
sell this next book.
So instead of sending out
this book again and again,
which was getting really
psychically difficult,
why don't you just put it aside
and focus on this new book?
And so I always said if I
didn't sell "California,"
I was going to become a
nurse, because I was like,
I just can't go through that
rejection process again.
It was a year of people being
like, you're not good enough.
You spent three
years on that book.
Sorry.
But then they
accepted it, so now I
don't have to be a nurse, which
I think is better for everyone.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Well, Edan,
thank you so much for coming.
EDAN LEPUCKI: Thank
you for having me.
Thank you so much for
hearing me blabber on.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]